there were words that zambian opposition
leader hakayinde chilema has waited
years to hear
i said for the declare
they said islama hakka in the s
to be president-elect of the republic of
zambia
his defeat of incumbent president edgar
longue came on their sixth try for the
top office and the supporters are
ecstatic
[Music]
their candidates want an outright
majority more than 50 percent of the
vote which means there will be no runoff
but now the daunting task of turning
around the economy begins
this country
has got a lot of challenges
the challenges which the zambian people
in their collective wisdom
have decided to lamp on the shoulders
of this one man
but we must be quick to say
that this one man
is equal to the task
zambia owes more than 12 billion dollars
to external companies and lenders the
high cost of living rising unemployment
and poverty were big concerns for voters
president elect hakayinde
is promising to turn around the economy
saying he can attract investment tackle
debt and corruption
the majority of registered voters were
young people and they turned out on
election day in some areas the turnout
was even as high as 90 percent and this
is really
a cry out by the people of zambia that
they want to be
noticed they don't want to be sidelined
by any government
[Music]
president
said the election was not free and fair
after incidents of violence against
ruling patriotic fund party agents in
three provinces
hishilema supporters reject that they
want the president-elect sworn into
office as soon as possible haru mutasa
al jazeera lusaka